not many people in the streets of Berlin
have even heard of the top candidate
from the party of European socialists
dad if he wants to be the next mayor of
Berlin but he won't be far evict
cuz i'll just tell me i'll give you a
hint his name's Martin shoots no idea
I'm not really into politics and how
about jean-claude juncker the sister
that's looks and Borges ex-banker
President of the European bank or
something placards of the top candidates
have been all over Germany streets for
weeks now but people still hardly know
who they are only about one in four of
those surveyed recognized martin short's
of the party of european socialists but
even fewer new who's Jean Claude yoga
from the European People's Party was
only about fifteen percent recalled ever
hearing his name the European
parliamentary election is upon us and
hardly anyone cares the European Union
itself doesn't seem to get many Germans
excited they associate EU politics with
red tape and silly regulations
appreciate regulating the curve of a
cucumber is the first thing that comes
to my mind he can't endorse that kind of
lunacy Ritson look if you hear anything
it's negative some restriction that has
to be observed usually by Germany or
some limitation having to do with
agriculture as Finn okay he use very
important but you don't hear much about
it so Germans interest in the European
parliamentary election is low around
sixty-two percent of those asks said
they had little or no interest in the
election only thirty-eight percent said
they had great interest so many
pollsters predict that voter turnout
will be even lower this time than for
the last european election